President Trump says the administration
is closely watching two major Florida
races where the recounts are underway
this morning in the contest for governor
Republican Rick Ron rather Rhonda
Sanchez leads Democrat Andrew Gilliam
49.5% to 49.1%
in the Senate race Republican rick scott
leads democrat bill nelson by an even
slimmer margin that's fifty percent to
forty nine point nine percent it's that
close both content both contests rather
are within the margin for mandatory
machine recounts Manuel Bojorquez is
inside the Broward County election
center in Lauderhill Florida man well
good morning good morning Gail most of
Florida's 67 counties are working 24/7
right now to try to recount 8.2 million
ballots and they have a Thursday
deadline to do that and that could be a
challenge one day after Democrat Andrew
Gilliam officially withdrew his
concession against Republican Ron de
santis partisan protesters continued
their raucous demonstrations in Broward
County when you cheat the system of
electing our officials it is no longer
We the People some Republicans including
the president have suggested Democrats
are trying to steal the election
Democrats say they're following state
guidelines for elections that are this
close we're here to make sure that all
the votes count
Republican Senate candidate Rick Scott
holds a razor-thin lead in the Senate
race against incumbent Democrat Bill
Nelson Scott filed a suit against
Supervisor of Elections Brenda Snipes
who the lawsuit claims failed to provide
the total vote count on schedule in
Broward County 205 valid ballots were
mixed with 22 rejected ones it's deja vu
all over again
remember Bush versus Gore in the 2000
presidential election that Florida
recount took more than five weeks and
untold lawsuits before george w bush was
declared the winner by 537 votes Sunday
night Andrew Gilliam took to the pulpit
preaching to his choir demand that every
vote be counted in this process and a
Carbonell is with the Rick Scott Senate
campaign everybody keeps saying here we
go again Florida Florida Florida what do
you say to that look the truth of the
matter is that 65 counties were able to
follow the law and make sure that the
process went as smoothly as possible
sadly two counties did not follow the
law the state's law enforcement agency
has said so far there is no evidence of
voter fraud now the Senate race could
end up in a second recount a hand
recount where workers would review
questionable ballots one by one to try
to determine voter intent and that could
lead to multiple court challenges Norah
we will continue to follow it closely
Manuel thank you so much